[музика]
поки в Україні триває повномасштабне
вторгнення Росії німецькі компанії не
зупиняють свою роботу ба більше деякі з
них розширюють своє виробництво в
Україні так наприклад компанія крайзель
будує вже другий завод із виготовлення
будівельних сумішей цього разу у
Львівській області тут
на паспорті об'єкту видно що ділянка 5
гектарів землі
потужність підприємства тут написано 100
тисяч тонн на рік але в процесі
проектування ще була збільшена
дві лінії буде 400 тисяч тонн на рік це
означає що це буде найбільше
підприємство з виробництва сухих
будівельних сумішей в Україні
буде стояти на сучасне обладнання де ми
будемо перевіряти саме якісні кількісні
характеристики нашої продукції і ніяка
продукція не може вийти з нашої
території якщо вона не відповідає
локальним нормам і нашим німецьким
нормам новий високотехнологічний завод
має запрацювати Вже наступного року він
входитиме у трійку найбільших виробництв
з цієї групи компаній
у нас в групі фіксіт 5 брендів з якими
ми працюємо ми в Україні розвиваємо
бренд fixed crysil і
фіксід має в Європі 52 заводи і
Враховуючи те що цей завод буде входити
в трійку найбільших найпотужніших
заводів фіксі-груп це говорить про те що
наші німецькі колеги бачать перспективи
в Україні бачать перспективу в розвитку
і будують
надсучасний високоефективний завод Який
буде виробляти високоякісну продукцію і
це дуже важливо Це піднімає технічну
технологічну будівельну культуру в
Україні і відповідно я певен що це були
стане з часом певними стандартами на
ринку України і весь ринок почне
підтягуватися до цих стандартів
сам завод почали будувати влітку 2021
року у лютому 22-го усі процеси зупинило
повномасштабне вторгнення та після
місяця паузи будівництво відновили після
місяця призупинення проекту було
прийнято рішення на рівні групи що ми
маємо рухатися далі І будувати тому що
війна піде а Україну треба буде
відбудовувати І саме відбудовувати
високоякісними матеріалами
високотехнологічними матеріалами і
крайзель має досвід в цьому в Європі і
Міг би допомогти Україні
для нас це було
як можемо зараз інвестувати там ударів
і на Львів і флісщини інакєшщині але
також було питання як це можливо саме
старше мільйони євро посилять у Камінь я
будувати що буде якщо
ракета літають і там буду в школі
великий тому важливим моментом стало
запровадження німецьким урядом механізм
страхування воєнних ризиків для
німецьких інвесторів і торговельних
компаній У рамках програми інвестиційних
гарантій компанія krazel першою в
Україні отримала державний страхування
від уряду Німеччини ця страховка
покриватиме усі ризики пов'язані з
війною а також трансферні ризики ризики
порушення договору тощо участь у цій
програмі передбачає одноразовий платіж і
щорічний внесок залежно від суми
покриття інвестиційного ризику
А це був ключовий момент ключовий момент
Ні тільки для нас але також для інших
інвесторів із Німеччини тому що
німецький дуже конкретний працює дуже
серйозно але також вони мають
професійний
риск менеджмент і звичайно як війна в
сім'ї і маємо війни тут маємо атаки
проти України це важко маю зараз
інформація може вам сказати ще в
Міністерство
у Німеччини в Німеччині мали зараз більш
А більш Пітан
[музика]
щоб далі інвестувати а це дуже
позитивний сигнал це політичний сигнал
це сигнальна
є майбутнє така урядова страхова
програма існувала і раніше проте тепер
до переліку додався пункт провоєнні
ризики таке рішення німецького уряду на
думку інвесторів свідчить про
впевненість Німеччини у майбутньому
України це сигнал німецькому бізнесу щоб
той не боявся інвестувати в Україну Це
було зрозуміло що це
потенційне майбутнє член Європейського
Союзу тому вкладати в Україну зараз це
вкладати в майбутнє саме Європейського
Союзу Тому це було логічно для нас да це
не було супербезпечно але це було по
партнерськи 12 мільйонів євро під час
війни це наш вклад подальший розвиток це
перспективи подальшого розвитку ми
говоримо не тільки про другий завод є
перспективи ще і про третій говорити про
третій завод Звичайно що для компанії це
цікаво і
компанія бачить перспективи розвитку
саме в Україні і якщо компанія в такі
непрості часи вкладає гроші в Україну Це
означає що це країна в якій компанія
приходить в серйозний надовго і хоче
розвиватися саме в цій країні за даними
німецько-української
торговельно-промислової палати загальна
сума інвестицій німецьких компаній
зменшилася у порівнянні з довоєнним
періодом нині найбільший інвестиції в
Україну надходить від концернів Bayer і
фіксід обидва роблять ця в рамках
програми інвестиційних гарантій від
німецького уряду
порівняно з до воєнним періодом Так
звичайно ризик є і компанії усвідомлюють
цей ризик тому припускає що інвестиції
було б більше якби не було війни І я
очікую що кількість інвестицій зросте
коли війну буде виграно це точно багато
компаній які зараз інвестують звісно
мають спеціальні плани щодо цих
інвестицій Вони отримують страховку
інвестиції що Звичайно є розумною річчю
але звісно за цими інвестиціями стоять
розрахунки щодо українського ринку і
віра в Україну що цей ринок буде
розвиватися далі І що ці інвестиції
будуть прибутковими
відколи Почала діяти програма
інвестиційних гарантій німецького уряду
кількість заявок на участь у ній
збільшилася це дозволить залучити ще
більше інвестицій в Україну під час
війни
Нещодавно я почув цифру Про те що існує
близько 50 заявок на гарантії інвестицій
в агентство яке займається цими заявками
50 Це досить значна цифра але як на мене
обсяги цих інвестицій не дуже великі
ймовірно десь від 10 до 100 мільйонів
євро окремі потрібно багато інвесторів
тут можна рибу ріпить руками це означає
це
дуже гарна країна дуже
добрі люди то кожен знає що має робити
тут
я думаю все це політичний сигналь і це
багато допомагає
у мінекономіки України Вважають що ця
німецька програма є вкрай важливим
інструментом для підтримки та
активізації бізнесу але не лише Україна
отримає від цього вигоду німецькі
компанії не інвестували б у ринок який
не обіцяє прибутків
якщо дивитися з точки зору Німеччини та
німецьких компаній то Україна величезним
ринком У Європі небагато країн із 40
мільйонів населенням тому потенційно це
великий ринок Звісно це теж певного роду
Ставка на післявоєнний період ми
розраховуємо на те що Україна буде
успішною І що після війни буде добре
розвиток як прогнозує український уряд
темпи зростання будуть від 5 до 7% на
рік крім того є ринковий потенціал а
також є потенціал кваліфікованої робочої
сили в Україні тому після війни буде
набагато більше інвестицій зважаючи на
українську винахідливість і великий
потенціал розширення німецьких
інвестицій в Україну допомагає великий
програмі відбудови України вже нині це
створює робочі місця вливає фінансову
економіку України і підвищує показники
виробництва і свідчить про те що німці
вірять у Великій економічний потенціал
України після війни